welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is everything you need to
know going into Invincible season 2 on
Amazon Prime video we're doing a full
recap of season 1 remember with one of
the most banana season finales of all
time and a little preview based off of
trailer footage headed into season 2 now
if you don't have time to rewatch season
1 let this Vite Take the Wheel so you
can go into the new season as fresh faed
as you were before your dad used you to
BCT a train we're doing a primer here to
bring you back into one of the best
superhero shows to come out in the past
few years I'm so so excited for
invincible and I can't wait to break
down each of these episodes by the way
new rock stars is doing a live show on
November 16th in Los Angeles at brain
dead Studios you can join me and Tommy
and some other special guests it's going
to be a lot of fun ticket info in the
description all right let's do a quick
overview of the eight episodes of season
1 and the hourlong Adam Eve origin
special that came out back in July to
recap everything you need to know and
we're going to look at some trailer
footage for season 2 okay the first
episode of invincible opens with an
attack on the White House by the merer
twins these hulk-like science clones who
each claimed to be the original clone
are going to be a big part of the story
moving forward and they're going to show
up in season 2 their attack is foiled by
the Guardians of the globe a super team
whose members are not that veiled
parodies of the members of the Justice
League their Superman analog is omn man
voiced by JK Simmons he is like Superman
in terms of his power set but unlike him
in some key ways like he's evil we meet
our main character Mark Grayson voiced
by Steven Yun we initially see him
reading comics on the toilet Mark is the
child of the superhero omn man Secret
ident named Nolan and the child of
Debbie a non-powered human voice by
Sandra o Mark assumes that he'll get his
powers at some point X-Men rules seem to
be in play here where superhuman
abilities manifest at puberty but at
this point he's just a normal teen who
goes to high school and works at a fast
food place but later that night at work
he tries tossing a garbage bag into the
dumpster and it Rockets into space a
classic moment right at the comics by
Robert Kirkman Cory Walker and Ryan
notley that this is based on yes Robert
Kirkman same as the creator of The
Walking Dead comics and if you watch The
Walking Dead you remember Carl at one
point reading Invincible comics in that
show show in an Easter egg now that
garbage bag that Mark tosses into the
sky does come back later in the season
but in a quick flashback Senter around
Mark omn man explains that he's from a
planet of supers called vilum and the
viltrumites have made it their duty to
protect other planets but it's not the
whole story throughout the season he
drops many hints that he is more of a
conqueror than a protector back in the
present Mark trains in flying and
fighting with his dad after having to
restrain himself from hitting a bully
Mark Don's a homemade costume and goes
out to fight crime to get his aggression
out you know kind of like help people
and stuff but his dad takes him to get a
proper costume via art Rosen bomb a
superhero tailor he takes on the name
invincible and he starts heroing and
we'll see how it's a regular bit on the
show to set up using the word Invincible
in a sentence but then we cut to the
show's title The Guardians of the globe
are called to their Hideout by omn man
who proceeds to kill them all and
suddenly it's totally a Robert Kirkman
thing because it is bloody and brutal
one of the Guardians is the immortal who
you guessed it is Immortal so we'll be
hearing from him later so in episode 2
we meet the government organization
known as the global Defense Agency and
and it's led by Cecil Stedman voiced by
Walton gogins he comes in for a cleanup
and assumes the now and aoma omn man was
a victim of whatever killed the other
Guardians Cecil is basically the Nick
Fury of the show this government has
developed some impressive technology
that gives Cecil the ability to teleport
in and out of places in an instant since
the world is down it's strongest Heroes
Mark steps up to help he meets the Teen
team the Invincible universe's version
of the Teen Titans it includes robot the
group's leader voiced by zacher Quinto
he appears to be an intelligent AI
housed in a robot body but he's actually
a drone controlled by a deformed and Ill
human Rudy Connor there's Rex explode
voiced by Jas manukas who has the
ability to charge molecules and make
objects explode pretty much like Gambit
from X-Men there's duplicate who can
create copies of herself and atom e
voiced by gilan Jacobs who is insanely
powerful and can manipulate atoms at the
molecular level in fact now would be a
good time to learn more about Adam Eve's
origin from Invincible atom Eve this
Adam Eve special goes deep into her
origin story it begins in a science lab
that's under attack by the lizard League
a super villain team inspired Ed by
Cobra from GI Joe they throw down with
the Guardians of the globe and during
the battle a scientist named Dr Elias
brandworthy he takes her to a hospital
pursued by a small army led by agent
Ericson played brilliantly by the late
great Lance reic to throw them off the
trail he sends the newborn super baby
off with an ordinary couple Adam and
Betsy Wilkins and tells ericon that the
mother died the baby is named Samantha
Eve Wilkins and grows up knowing that
she's different she's kind of a prodigy
when it comes to chemistry and at the
age of 12 she unlocks her ability to
manipulate matter naturally she masks up
and starts heroing as Adam Eve during
one of her battles she meets up with
Brandy worth who has been keeping tabs
on her he gives her a mostly true
version of her origin that she was a lab
experiment made to be a weapon but he
tells her that her mother was his lab
assistant when she was really just a
homeless woman he also tells her that he
installed power dampeners in her so that
she can only manipulate non-living
matter Eve then gets into a fight with a
gang of modified kids led by Phase 2
phase two and the others were made in
the same lab that Eve was these Living
Weapons are clearly inspired by the
technum hybrids of a Kira Eve takes out
her kind of siblings in a truly
spectacular battle but it's taken back
to Ericson's lab there Ericson kills
Brandy worth and reveals that he has
been using Eve's not dead after all
mother to create his experiments Eve
subverts her power dampeners and goes
all dark Phoenix Super Saiyan on ericon
but doesn't kill him she returns to her
Suburban home with the knowledge of her
true origin oh one shot energy huh I
think I'll try
it
so what does one shot's Focus shoe
[Music]
do
eternity
wa so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with one shot
energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com neww rockstars for 10% off
your order okay back to episode 2 in the
main Invincible storyline we learned
that even Mark go to the same school and
are both maintaining ordinary teen
secret identities we also have a little
love triangle between Mark and Eve in
the non-powered Amber voiced by ZZ beats
the GDA keeps investigating the
Guardians murders with Paranormal
Investigator and Hellboy Constantine R
shark riff character Damian dark blood
omn man comes out of his coma and
returns home and continues to train Mark
during a practice space fight mark meets
the alien Allen voiced by Seth Rogan
he's an Intergalactic bureaucrat who
checks them periodically with omn man to
make sure he's appropriately protecting
Earth Mark and the Teen team fight a
very persistent group of alien Vaders
named The flaxin omn Man swoops in to
help and then he goes absolutely AP
on the flaxon home planet this confirms
that the brutality we saw him used
against the Guardians was all him and
not any kind of mind control on episode
three back in the teen drama plot Mark
finally asks Amber out Rex Spode who was
dating atam cheats on her with duplicate
robot is put in charge of forming a new
Guardians of the globe and he chooses
black Samson a former member of the
Guardians with superhuman strength and
shrinking Reay who has the power to
shrink also monster girl who has the
ability to turn into a huge beast but
every time she does her regular form
Dees a little she used to be called
Monster woman but now her regular
appearance is that of a young girl
despite being the age 24 the rest of the
new Guardians is rounded out with Rex
blow duplicate and Adam Eve Cecil calls
on Mark to help the Guardians creating
some tension with Amber because he's
always creating excuses for why he has
to run off and save the world meanwhile
the M WIS Escape from Super Jail and one
of them used the other as a human shield
or I guess you could say clone Shield
before running off deia started to
suspect that her husband is hiding
something and dark blood is convinced
that omn man is guilty in episode four
Olga the wife of deceased Guardians of
the globe member red Rush is upset at
her husband's death and ask Debbie to
help her sell her house meanwhile Mark
volunteers to protect human astronauts
from martians on their first trip to the
red planet in place of omn man after a
skirmish with the Martians Mark gets the
astronauts back to the shuttle unbeknown
to them one of the astronauts was
replaced with a Martian and kind of of
an alien infection storyline that seems
like it might come back in season 2
while Invincible is on Mars Nolan takes
Debbie on a lunch date to Rome to regain
her trust and spend quality time with
her Cecil thinks Nolan intentionally
killed the Guardians of the globe but
sends dark blood back to Hell dark blood
intentionally left his gnarly book of
notes in Debbie's closet one of the mer
twins clones himself as they love to do
and unbeknownst to anyone robot enlists
their help to make a new human body for
himself without anyone's knowledge of
permission his new body will be made out
of Rex explodes DNA after omn man in
Debbie's trip Debbie finds dark blood's
notes and Nolan's bloodied omn suit in
their house oh episode five markets
guilted in helping street level criminal
Titan with a mission to take down
Machine Head a Kingpin black mask type
super villain but as Mark eventually
finds out it's a trap battle Beast gets
the jump on invincible and severely
injures him black Samson and monster
girl Machine Head is arrested by the GDA
and Mark and Company get taken in for
treatment Titan being the desperate yet
diabolical smart tactician that he is
takes over Machine Head's criminal
Enterprise and is able to protect his
own family Eve decides that she's had
enough of being a superhero and decides
to help Amber volunteer at the soup
kitchen meanwhile GDA scientists test
Mark's blood to see that it is
impervious to every test they administer
maybe he really is Invincible episode 6
Mark is out of the hospital and patches
things up with Amber just in time for
their college weekend trip with their
friend will they're going to visit
Upstate University to see Will's crush a
student there named Rick a mad scientist
at Upstate you named da Sinclair lets a
dangerous cyborg out of his secret lir
on campus Mark steps away to turn into
Invincible to fight the cyborg but
Sinclair kidnaps Rick and turns him into
a cyborg Invincible defeats cyborg Rick
with help from a pleading will will
appealing to Rick's heart helps break
the hold Sinclair had on him so Mark
could do his thing the GDA and Cecil
arrive on campus to clean up the mess
and Cecil get Sinclair to make cyborgs
for him superhero suit Taylor art Rosen
bomb uses omn Man suit to help confirm
to Debbie that he did indeed kill the
Guardians of the globe so Debbie gets
drunk and confronts Nolan about the
murders but Adam Eve is out doing her
own thing helping people all over the
world separating her herself from her
unsupportive parents and other
superheroes who don't get her she's got
a treeh house home base Adam Eve wants
to skip college and continue to help
people with their powers meanwhile robot
having studied her before the Titan
snafu helps restore monster girl the
MERS revive Immortal while they continue
to help robot grow a body turns out it
is hard to kill a hero named Immortal on
to episode seven Debbie and Nolan's
marriage is irrevocably damaged now that
she knows he hasn't been honest with her
they argue he flies through the roof
Cecil knows that omn man killed the
Guardians he brings Debbie to the GDA
and tells while sending agents to try to
subdue omn man and it doesn't go great
and Cecil and Debbie watch from the GDA
as omn man wipes out the strike force
Cecil's assistant and high-ranking GDA
agent Donald Ferguson dies in this
bloodbath the Rex clone named Rudy pays
the MERS but sets them up as he escapes
to the Guardians omn man now is Big mad
and Cecil releases the reenan a Kaiju
and the immortal to slow omn man down
but they don't and they just make omn
man even matter Mark finally decides to
tell Amber that he's Invincible but she
dumps mark upon hearing that because she
already knew and she's been upset that
he didn't share this with her sooner
Mark finally finds out what's going on
with his dad and he rushes off to defeat
the Kaiju onto episode 8 the season
finale Nolan tells Mark the truth that
he is a viltrumite who sent as a scout
to infiltrate Earth and prepare it for
the vites to come take it over the vites
are actually an imperialistic superhuman
Spartan society that Valu strength and
call any weakness from their ranks they
want to expand their empire throughout
the Galaxy and conquer any planet that
gets in their way that's why he killed
the Guardians of the globe because Earth
had evolved to the point of being ready
for Vite integration and the Guardians
would just get in the way of that omn
man asks Mark to join him in helping
conquer Earth but Mark refuses citing
the fact that Earth is a great Planet as
is and Mark himself is half human but
Nolan just keeps killing people in front
of invincible to try to convince him and
Mark keeps trying to save them to no
avail like at one point omnimancer
killing everyone inside there's one
Survivor who nearly makes it in the
rubble but omn man just crushes all hope
it is the bleakest superhero TV has ever
been in my opinion omn man tells Mark
that his mother Debbie is less of a wife
and more of a pet and Debbie here's this
omn man beats Mark bloody in the side of
a mountain he tells Mark that their
lives will go on for thousands of years
and that all the humans are important to
them now but will be dead and gone Nolan
asks who will you have in 500 years and
Mark bloodied and defeated just croaks
out I'll have you and Nolan doesn't know
how to respond to this and flies away
from Earth leaving Mark beat into a PO
so Mark recovers after a couple weeks
Amber deduces what really happened with
omn man and rushes to be at Mark's side
when he comes home along with Will and
Eve Mark and Amber get back together Cil
calls Mark and warns him about a figure
flying directly towards Earth worried
that it's his father Mark flies into
space to find out that it's just Allen
the alien mark tells him everything
about omn man and Allan warns him that
the vites will definitely be coming back
to Earth to wipe them out just like they
did his home planet and to end the
season we get a montage of all the
threats we've met this season being put
into place for a potential return in
seon season 2 martians being overrun by
squids the flaxon regrouping Titan
running his criminal Empire and the MERS
being imprisoned again but the GDA is
preparing for omn Man 2 by helping the
immortal recover and building an army of
cyborgs with help from Sinclair so what
can we expect in season 2 based on
trailer footage we know that we'll be
learning more about omn man and the
vites we're also going to pick up with
Mark and his mother Debbie as they both
come to terms with omn man's true nature
as a Vite Vanguard an alien Invader Mark
looking ahead to college is questioning
his purpose as a superhero like when
you're the son of a super villain does
that make you destined to grow up and be
just like them how much of omn man's
blood and soul actually runs in Mark the
trailer hints at a dark future people of
Earth the more you resist the worse this
gets and if you think you can stop us
don't forget I'm but also in season 2
Sterling K Brown is going to be joining
the cast is a new character named
angstrom Levy a character who seems to
have connections to the Multiverse
there's an infinite number of dimensions
and I was born with with the ability to
access all of them a multiversal
traveler seems to be the best defense
against omn man in the full power of the
Vite Empire so our breakdown of season 2
episode 1 is going to be coming in the
next few days we got a lot recovering
right now on new rockstars from Loki
episode 5 the Gen V finale But after
those breakdowns come out we're going to
get to this invincible Premiere
subscribe to all three channels in the
new rockstars Network a big thanks to
Eric auu Jordan Morris Eric Francisco
and Brandon bar for writing this video
follow me at avos thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time
bye
[Music]